CITIZENSHIP HELPING THE GROUP,
DANA.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHY WE BRING IN
TOM HOMAN FORMER ACTING
DIRECTOR OF ICE.
I WAS STUNNED LOOKING AT THE QR
CODE.
TOM, THE ADMINISTRATION SAID
THEY HAVE MADE IT VERY CLEAR TO
THE MIGRANTS SAYING DO NOT COME.
THEY ARE SO ORGANIZED I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO MAKE A QR CODE.
THEY HAVE THIS THING.
THAT'S HOW YOU SIGN UP TO GET
ABOARD.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS LOOK, WE
HAVE THE FIRST PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY OF THIS NATION THAT
CAME INTO OFFICE WITHIN DAYS
AND INTENTIONALLY UNSECURED THE
MOST SECURE BORDER WE EVER HAD,
DANA.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP WE HAD
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION DOWN 81%.
MOST SECURE BORDER IN MY ENTIRE
CAREER OF 35 YEARS.
MOST SECURE BORDER IN MY
LIFETIME AND WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT CAME IN WITHIN
DAYS AND UNSECURED THE BORDER
AND WE HAVE A SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY HELPING HIM
DO THAT.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE.
WHEN YOU UNSECURE THE BORDER,
THAT'S WHEN -- THERE IS NO DOWN
SIDE SECURING THE BORDER.
LESS DRUGS, LESS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
LESS WOMEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
AND LESS WOMEN DYING AND LESS
OPIOIDS COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
THAT KILLED OVER 94,000 PEOPLE
THIS YEAR.
HE INTENTIONALLY UNSECURED THE
BORDER.
THE MOST UNPRESIDENTIAL THING I
EVER HEARD.
HE AND HIS SECRETARY SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT IS
ASSISTING THE CARAVANS TO THE
GET TO THE U.S. BORDER.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP MEXICO
HAD MILITARY ON THE NORTH AND
SOUTH BORDER AND HELPED US
SECURE.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT HELPED
MORE TO SECURE THE BORDER THAN
A DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS.
IT IS BY DESIGN.
NOT INCOMPETENCE OR
MISMANAGEMENT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT AND WHY
THEY HAVEN'T DONE ONE THING,
NOT ONE THING TO SLOW THE FLOW.
>> Bill: WOULD WOULD THIS BE BY
DESIGN?
WHAT WOULD BE THE ULTIMATE
INTENT?
YOU HAVE THE JUDGE'S ORDER TO
REMAIN IN MEXICO TO GO INTO
ACTION IN NOVEMBER.
WE ASSUME IT WILL TAKE PLACE.
ONE OF THE BIG TOOLS YOU USED
TO KEEP MIGRANTS ON THE
SOUTHERN SIDE OF THE BORDER.
EXPLAIN YOURSELF.
>> THE PRESIDENT SOLD OUT TO
THE PROGRESSIVE LEFT TO WIN THE
ELECTION NOW KEEPING HIS
PROMISE.
THEY TRULY BELIEVE IN THEIR
HEARTS, FUTURE DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS, THEY DON'T HAVE TO VOTE.
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS BEING
COUNTED IN THE NEXT CENSUS.
THESE ARE -- THEY THINK THIS
WILL LEAD TO PERPETUAL POWER IN
CONGRESS AND LEAD TO THEM BEING
IN POWER TO CONGRESS FOR YEARS
TO COME.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON YOU WANT
AN INSECURE BORDER.
NOBODY WANTS MORE DRUGS AND
CARTELS MAKING MILLIONS AND
PEOPLE DYING.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP HE
ACTUALLY -- THE WALL AND
EVERYTHING HE DONE.
IF IMMIGRATION WAS DOWN 83% HOW
MANY LIVES ARE SAVED.
HOW MANY MILLIONS DID THE
CARTELS MAKE AND HOW MANY
CHILDREN DIDN'T DIE?
>> Dana: I HAVE A THOUGHT, TOO.
APPARENTLY THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO GET THE
RECONCILIATION BILL DONE AND
REPORTS ME MIGHT TRY TO ADD
IMMIGRATION REFORM INCLUDING
AMNESTY INTO THAT BILL TO GET
IT DONE.
THAT DOESN'T REALLY SEND A
SIGNAL TO MIGRANTS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T COME TO THE BORDER.
>> NO.
EVERYTHING THEY ARE DOING, THE
SECRETARY LAST WEEK SENT A MEMO
OUT TO ICE.
BASICALLY SAYING BEING IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY IS NO LONGER
ENOUGH TO MAKE AN ARREST.
HE SAID BEING ILLEGALLY IN THE
UNITED STATES IS NO LONGER
ILLEGAL.
NO REASON TO ARREST AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN.
THEY HAVE TO BE CONVICTED OF A
SERIOUS CRIME.
CONGRESS TALKING ABOUT AMNESTY
SENDS A MESSAGE.
WHEN YOU STOP BUILDING THE WALL
THAT SENDS A MESSAGE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION EVERY STEP
THEY'VE TAKEN SENDS THE WRONG
MESSAGE AND WONDER WHY THE
NUMBERS ARE INCREASING?
WE WENT FROM THE MOST SECURE
BORDER TO AN HISTORIC HIGH THIS
PAST YEAR MORE ILLEGAL CROSSING
THAN EVER IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS NATION.
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE
PROGRESSIVES.
THEY'RE WINNING THE WAR ON THIS.
>> Bill: THANK YOU FO